hi Bernie hi I'm questions as in the
United States and I'm promoting TNT and
we would like to say in 2008 we think
there needs to be more of a
concentration and education especially
for children developing countries who
are given that opportunity we must not
only invest in education but at the same
time and sustainable economic
development in this country's but
boosting agriculture but by creating
awareness of their body of education in
the future but at the same time create
strengthening institutions creating
employment for the people but to leave
the country afterwards and have the
great one of our great problem whether
it'll work great a lot of times you will
become educated and because there's not
the economic stability or the economic
institutions and complete structures in
the country there's no place for them
early to go until if you create economic
incentives and economics program so
these people came though then go and use
and they won't have to leave they can
stay in our country and it can continue
to make this country a better place and
eradicate poverty essentially in their
area but the main problem with brain in
trainee asleep people from the
developing countries and will go to
another developed countries and all the
innovations of the good ideas that they
have implemented in the developed world
in developed countries not producing
innovation and uh producing development
in the
that's why one of the key questions I'm
addressing the poverty issues in this
country is not only investing in
education but strengthening in the end
institutions the infrastructure building
infrastructure and also at the same time
I said before the create creation of
employment for the people not to leave
the country and could have a good work
in the return now every year in North
America we spend 20 billion dollars and
ice cream it would only cost ten billion
dollars the building after school's put
all the world's children to school so I
think about that the next time you buy
ice cream think about the little actions
that you can do that can really change
the world because there is a lot we can
do it through charities through NGOs
through un through so many organizations
you can change the world every day on a
daily basis I simply decided not to eat
ice cream one day and donated the money
to build a school or to loan out through
someone else starting a company or
business the main the main we must hurt
tourism and the government to solve the
problems but we must be an integral part
of solving that problem it is a it's
only through the balance of the
individuals other governments that we
can tackle the major world problems such
as poverty and lack of education global
warming we should act as a community
respecting each another state vs thank
you so much and by time we challenge you